welcome back to do rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse I'm marina Mastro's and now that
Spiderman far from home is available on
digital HD we are now able to dig back
through this film and find the details
that we missed the first time around and
also to yell at Brad rad sucks
one thing that we know about director
John watts more than most other
directors he loves to hide Easter eggs
and car license plates yeah weird
just like his thing spider-man
homecoming was full of them including a
Howard the Duck reference that Eric
ruined his life finding yes my
relationships are crumbling but it's all
for you with this clue hunting spirit in
mind marina and I are gonna go back
through spider-man far from whom zoom in
enhance on every visible license plate
and explain what new stuff that we found
in this rewatch it's a plate down marina
yeah
how do those plates baby it's our clean
plate Club we don't Plato we begin in
Mexico in the Films opening scene Nick
Fury and Maria hill pass a wrecked car
with the license plate for 63 ga-oh and
this shows up on the trailer for the
film it's a reference to the comic issue
amazing spider-man number 4 which came
out in 1963 for 63 which was the
introduction to the villain Sandman
Flint Marko right now of course this was
the first of many mr. X and far from
home because this monster eats a man
writes an elemental holo projection
watts knew the super nerds would be
looking for clues trying to fool us
nice try watts we fell for it actually
the trailers also included other tag
numbers just to throw us off a number on
a Venice boat behind Ned referencing
Hydra man Morrie bench and a tag number
on a car on Tower Bridge referencing
Moulton man both were removed from the
theatrical cut of the film because both
were allies but as you watch the film
more license plates do appear the bus
that Dimitri drives through the Alps
features the tag NK 6224 are the snow
you can figure out what that was a
reference to and then later in Prague
the Audis that fury hill and their team
drive up might have some clues as well
we know the one that hill drives is
tagged ASM 28 965 which like that cut
tag from the trailer is a nod to amazing
spider-man number 28 released in
September 1965 the introduction of
molten man which this prog elemental is
taking inspiration from
the other Audi's have tags to GNL eight
three two two six ARL four seven two six
eight one that looks like three
something something fifty two these
could be references to something let us
know if you decode whatever secret these
Audi's are hiding because if we could
not yes I mean it may be if they were la
with me I'm an [ __ ] that's too much
money and doesn't know how to drive
where Nick Fury picks up Spider Man aka
night monkey at this point in a car
tagged into you eighty three seven seven
nine now this is a reference to Marvel
team-up issue 83 released July nineteen
seventy nine eight three seven seven
nine an issue in which Nick Fury and
Peter Parker appear together as they do
in the scene and in this comic fury
attacks Peter and Fury's organizations
being corrupted all things that are
about to happen in this coming sequence
moving on to London where Goodman picks
up the students in a double-decker bus
tagged LJ v for bfk then something odd
happens okay
later when he parks the bus on Tower
Bridge the first group of numbers on the
tag has actually changed to my s what oh
yeah is this possible perhaps my s is
actually miss for Mysterio the name that
the whole team is now adopted
collectively okay perhaps goo Turman
swapped the plates to cover his tracks
or maybe it's an illusion things in
illusion between three letters now this
bridge is filled with vehicles and tags
that we're not sure about there's like a
motorcycle tag w j66 Y SS a black car
tagged Y t12 DFC then there's a blue
Audi tagged LT o 8rg be another way car
tag ovo for Jackson but then we stumble
upon one that's actually a pretty cool
reference there's a blue Beemer tagged
m95 XLV now xov is a Roman numeral 445
and the astonishing spider-man number 45
released in 1995 was the debut of XI
vanam revealed in film last year as
Eddie Brock's ex-girlfriend and took on
the symbiote and with his latest Sony
Disney divorce a world with she venom
could be where Tom Hall and Peter Parker
is headed next it's very possible to the
next time we see Peter Parker on screen
will be in a venom crossover and now the
car beside it we're not so sure about
the plate is VX
c6x AE but then there's one we decoded
tsa m14 three that is for the amazing
spider-man issue 143 in which spider-man
battles cyclone similar to the elemental
of this battle back in the airport in
the u.s. Aunt May picks up Peter in her
car tagged Ana 1562 we saw this tag
number back in spider-man homecoming and
they kept it the same for this movie
which is pretty cool that is for amazing
fantasy issue 15 1962
spider-man's first ever comic appearance
and finally in the film's post-credit
scene Nick Fury and Maria Hill or should
we say scrawl versions of them drive a
car tagged H in m6 2011 this is a
reference to Hawkeye and Mockingbird
number six released in 2011 a storyline
that features Nick Fury as girl is a
school just like humans what new details
debut spot in your far from home
rewatched comment down below with your
thoughts hit that like button and
subscribe into rock stars for breakdowns
of everything Marvel marina mastress
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at a
loss thanks for joining us for this
plate down mmm lead tectonic plate we
did a deep dish dive that's right this
plate yeah that's right
enough with the platitudes later game
down quite flat I got nothing
I'm out